I worked at McDonald's I got fired I
worked at a furniture store I got fired
I worked in a car dealership I was fired
six times from the same guy and I've
been fired so many times I finally
figured out how to get fired and keep my
job I'm a sales guy because not because
I wanted to that was not something I
wanted to do my dad told my mom before
he died tell those boys to learn how to
sell he knew he was going to die and
he's like tell those boys to learn how
to sell and they can go anywhere my mom
didn't tell me that until I was like 25
26 years old and I had to take a sales
job she she wanted me to be a more a
professional so I went and got an
accounting degree got out of college
there was 25 unemployment I didn't know
it I didn't go to college and become a
Salesman but it was the only job I could
get when I was 25 years old it was be
unemployed or take this job selling
Toyotas I didn't even know what a Toyota
was so I took this job that I did I
thought it was just going to be a
temporary job I said okay I'm gonna do
this for until I can get a real job and
that ended up becoming my career I
actually hated sales because all the
jobs I had outside of McDonald animals
were part-time sales jobs I sold clothes
yeah I remember selling clothes I'd sell
I'd sell an outfit I'd make six bucks on
it
so kind of hard to get excited about six
dollars but it was six dollars more than
I had and I was trying to put myself
through college and
and pay for all kind of ridiculous
things I was doing at the time and
um I leaned into the sales thing and
started learning it I was just shooting
some material today for Cardone
University we we have probably without
me over promoting my own product we we
probably have the most
viewed the sales training system in the
world today
and I'm saying that not to brag but to
tell the viewer this came out of a job I
didn't want and didn't like
but when I leaned into it and said hey I
need to commit to this thing because I'm
just gonna I have to learn how to do
this
I have to learn how to bring Revenue in
and whether I liked it or not I needed
to learn I needed to learn the money
game the money game starts with in
accounting and it might have been the
thing I learned in accounting as I sit
here and tell you the story because in
accounting the top
I remember studying financial statements
in accounting classes uh it was
accounting
um the principles of accounting I
thought I was gonna learn how to make
money that's not what they're teaching
there but I remember there was on a page
in the accounting book The Blue
accounting book that I detested and
hated there was a page about an income
statement and then they would compare
income statements to these companies
well the top thing of every page was
income revenue or gross sales
and later looking back didn't know it
then but looking back later I'm like oh
that's the most important part of a
company
if it wasn't the most important part of
a company they wouldn't put it at the
top of the income State yeah on every
income statement everywhere in the world
it doesn't matter whether you're in
China or Chicago
the top three lines they might be
different words there it is all
describing gross sales uh revenue
revenue by Department
uh gross demand domestic product how
much uh revenue is coming through a
country that is what determines whether
or not a household a department or a
company is viable
and I had been fighting the top three
lines of my personal
financial statement which everybody has
one
and it's called sales so once I leaned
into it boom I started making money man
it was it was literally that simple I'm
going to learn how to bring Revenue into
my household
I was 25 years old had no money lived in
a lived in an apartment my rent was 275
dollars a month I was laid on it four
times a year
every three months I was late because
I'd go up and down
and when I leaned into it I was sudden
like hey I made an extra thousand
dollars uh when I was 25 years old I'm
like wow that was the most important
money I've ever made in my whole life
because it gave me an idea that I could
control my income if you want to make
more money you want to make big money
you have to start thinking on a bigger
scale
and that might sound obvious as I say it
but recognizing your own limiting
thinking where you're playing small is
one of the most challenging things to do
I think in the world I am where I'm at
because I'm also I've thought big enough
but also I'm not at a higher level
because I'm not thinking bigger period
it's really hard and so here's a quick
example there was uh two days ago I was
talking to an entrepreneur friend of
mine and he's built he's built a decent
business inside of one year he's got a
quarter Million Dollar business right
that's pretty good business for for one
year and he went from
you know being let go from his job and
starting this company and now he's at a
quarter million in revenue and he
messages me just as a as a fun thing to
do and he's like hey I'm doing a points
run where should I go
okay if you could fly anywhere where
would you go on a points run like what's
a points run and he said I'm I'm
qualifying for uh one of the airlines to
get a certain level a certain tier with
them and I need to get a certain number
of points so that I can qualify to get
in and said oh I don't know I don't I
pay zero attention to that if you're
thinking about going somewhere
instead of flying this is how you
upgrade this is how you make more money
right it's upgrading the thinking he's
trying to solve the problem of I need to
get into the Points Club so that I can I
can get whatever marginal benefits from
being in that club
and I said you know what you should be
thinking of instead of flying economy to
some city that is however many miles
away you need to get your points what
you should be doing is thinking how do I
make it worth my time to fly somewhere
where I can afford to fly business class
and land a five-figure deal as a result
of being there
he's got
a couple clients right now that if he
could go and visit them we were just on
on a call and he's talking about how one
of his clients is having a hard time
figuring out a standard operating
procedure of how they should be applying
the knowledge he's given them and and
train their team on how to do it right
that that was a problem that just came
up for them like we love what you're
telling us we love your offering we're
having a hard time executing it and
making it standard procedure
the next call that he's doing with them
was going to be to train them and how to
do it great hey instead of thinking
about a points run how about you go fly
there
and say you know what I'll spend a day
with you
sitting down training you on how to do
this
this is a client that is already
mid-fight favorite client a year for him
that could easily become a low
six-figure client a year for him so he
could more than double the business
if they execute on his ideas right
because he's not in there doing all the
work but this could this could more than
double his business with this one client
with with no real extra added cost or
expense to him just pure income at the
top
so instead of hopping on the zoom call
with them and training them and going
back and forth on email how about you
fly there spend a day with them build
the relationship even deeper with them
because he's never actually met them in
person
and that way you you take your points
run you still get your points and
qualify for whatever discounts you get
and benefits you can fly business class
there have a much better experience and
end up doubling the business with your
client and getting an extra five six
figures as a result of it like this is
the upgrade in the thinking you want to
make bigger money you have to start
thinking about bigger thinking and I
fully acknowledge that I'm not thinking
big enough for where I want to go you
know every time I I think I'm thinking
big I'll watch a Grant Cardone video or
I'll watch an Elon Musk video and Elon
Musk is talking about having a backup
plan for the planet that's why we're
going to Mars I watch a Steve Jobs video
of taking a dent in the universe and I
realize oh my gosh I'm thinking so small
you know I'm doing nothing not in a bad
way in an inspiring positive way to say
man you could be doing so much more come
on man let's go
so it's still my biggest problem too
it's the hardest thing to catch
because for him
and his environment and his friends and
how he grew up
a points run is is correct thinking you
know getting the discount codes is the
right thinking
the challenge with that is you're
spending time looking for the best deal
and looking to save a hundred dollars
here or a couple hundred dollars there
and you're using your mental energy up
on small problems
what my friend is doing is using his
mental energy up on trying to save a
couple thousand dollars when he could be
adding six figures to his business with
the same mental energy
now luckily you know he brought it up
and I was able to call him out on it and
and suggest a better path forward
if he hadn't it it was a joke I think
when he sent it like where would I where
should I go on a points run
I don't think he expected the answer
that I gave him but I think the only way
to to get this is to be around the
people who can call it out in you either
physically I think that's the best the
challenge is it's as you as you get
bigger as you grow more there's fewer
people who are ahead of you who can push
you
right there's fewer people who can look
at what you're doing and say hey this is
nothing play bigger in a loving way like
push you in a loving way as you climb
the ladder there's very there's fewer
and fewer people at the top of the
ladder who are ahead of you right and so
yes you want to give back and you want
to serve and as you learn you reach back
and you pull somebody else up to your
level but constantly finding somebody
that's why I love
um
I love Mastermind groups I love coaching
I love tapping into experts on different
topics because they pull me up uh even
if I'm an expert at something I want to
talk to my friends who are experts and
people who are ahead of me because they
push me to be better and if you don't
know those people yet
what are your options well you could
join group programs
right for example movement makers I love
my movement makers program it's 49 bucks
a month and we meet every two weeks and
you get to learn from me and there's
other amazing humans who are trying to
build up their platforms as well and
become thought leaders and experts but
if it's not my program there's tons of
other programs out there who do you
connect with who do you love who do you
look up to and you get a little bit of
you may not be able to afford to fly
there and meet them but you can learn
from them even in a group setting if you
can't afford that you know 49 bucks a
month or 97 bucks a month or whatever
the programs are is too much for you
then even the free content even even
what I'm doing even these videos here
you get a little bit from some super
successful person every time I make a
video if you even just consistently
watch those I've learned a ton from Elon
Musk and and uh Jeff Bezos and Steve
Jobs and people who I've never met
through my own videos and they push me
and they challenge me they can't
specifically call me out they can't say
hey Evan what you're doing right here
this thing that you're doing like the
points run is small right you shouldn't
be doing that but they can at least give
me encouragement and motivation in in
seeing what they're doing inspires me to
want to do something bigger again when I
see Elon Musk talking about a backup
plan for the planet it forces a lens of
reflection on what am I doing and is it
big enough and do I am I playing too
small a game
and so
if you want to
make more money and figure out the money
game you have to stop spending your time
on smaller problems and again it's a
super obvious thing to say but it's so
incredibly hard to actually apply
you could spend your time thinking about
big problems or you could spend your
time thinking about small problems and
there was a line in my Venture Capital
days
where
the smallest deal we would do is 500 000
and the biggest deal we would do was in
the 15 million range raising capital for
people and the senior Partners would
always say it takes just as much work to
do a 15 million dollar deal as it does
to do a 500 000 deal
same amount of work if anything the 15
million dollar deal is easier because
the people are more sophisticated if you
think about your clients the ones who
are paying more
are often your better clients the ones
who are paying less the ones who are
trying to negotiate a discount on
everything the cheapest clients that you
have are probably the ones who take the
most time who cause the most problems
give you the most aggravation
so
even if you can't go all on in on it
right now
spend a little bit more of your time
focus on bigger problems
bigger opportunities
because what you've got inside you
lends itself to something much bigger
than what you're doing right now than
what I'm doing right now
and by focus on playing that bigger game
I'm a bigger impact too
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
one thing about it one thing nobody can
say that I don't like I use information
I use experiences I leverage everything
like I can I'm a I consume
and I multiply I don't just consume and
too many people just consume and never
use
so what do you mean by that they're just
they're consuming information but
they're never applying it yeah you you
you you're either a consumer a producer
or an investor and and I'm all three I
consume it I produce own it and then I
invest in it when I started Twitter
account I had no followers when I
started Facebook account no followers I
was my first follower when I started
Instagram account no followers
um I didn't know how to post video I
didn't know how to take a selfie I
didn't know how to do any of this but I
did have a commitment
to grow in my finances
and if you want to grow your finances
attention is the Gateway
you want to go to heaven who wants to go
to heaven
You Gotta Die
he's telling you man you got to die to
go to the heaven
and most people don't want to die they
want to go to heaven but they don't want
to die most people want money but
they're not willing to get the attention
they're not willing to do
the Duke to get the attention and
including spending money
and I would just tell you this if you
want to change your financial condition
the first thing you need to do is go out
and Market in the marketplace so that
you can create a lead and not worry
about whether there's Roi or not it's so
stupid that people like what's the ROI
dude what's the ROI if nobody knows you
okay what's the ROI if I don't know your
name don't know your company don't know
what you do don't know your service
don't know your product don't know where
you're located what is the ROI okay best
product does not win today the best
known product wins you think Starbucks
sells the best coffee
nasty
[Music]
okay
but it's close
and I know what I'm getting when I get
there McDonald's they will sell the best
hamburger
close and available you need to think of
way bigger than you're thinking I
started in the apartment game uh 25
years ago in San Diego California my
first deal first deal I ever bought was
one unit this little yellow house that I
paid 78 000 for by the way all this
landscaping that's one of the things I'm
known for I'm like I'm putting trees up
there because that's going to give me
some extra rent it didn't by the way my
next deal was 38 units
okay it was easier buying 38 units than
it was one the only difference was to
think
I had to think different got to make a
few more phone calls but the play is
bigger right the reason people the
reason so many real estate people are
like marginal people no offense
raise your hand if you're marginal
they left raise your hand if you're a
liar yeah
look I'm marginal
compared to my potential
the fact that there's people in this
room that don't know me I've written
seven books 13 best-selling business
programs uh I have I'm probably the top
one or two maybe three social media
people in the world seven million people
on Facebook but seven million people on
Facebook is nothing compared to seven
billion people in the world problems are
opportunities the bigger the problems if
you could look for the giant problems on
this planet and quit complain about them
right and quit blaming somebody about
them and say man what if I took
responsibility for that problem
because there is money in solving
problems
you solve a problem
you'll end up with money and the bigger
the problem you solve
the bigger the problem you solve the
more money you end up with first 35 40
years of my life I was being held back
by what I knew
truth it wasn't the truth
the truth people and companies that are
buying private jets
that are hooking up with whoever they
want when they want that are spending
millions and millions and millions of
dollars on connections
and speed and access
dude what are they doing man what are
they doing okay they're doing something
different than you and I were taught to
do the school systems don't teach you
this your mama didn't teach you this
your daddy didn't teach it
your family doesn't know this right so
you got to go outside your circle of
influence
you have 12 14 million 6 million 4
million
[Music]
a little guy a little guy right here got
the big jet on the tarmac how's the
little guy like me end up making it all
the way up to food chain because I
studied those guys
and you can do the same thing if you
study hard enough the right people
not those guys those are the pilots okay
see they work for 150 Grand a year and
think they're they're cutting a big fat
hog in the ass well I make 175 000 but
they stop learning what the owner knows
okay study man study pay the price for
the information and then pay for the
price of access to the people and learn
from them if I could go back to my 20
year old self what I would tell my 20
year old self is one thing
get your money right son worry about the
money and now I know a lot of people
think that this is not the thing people
should be focused on however on this
planet if you don't get your money right
you're going to be worried all the day
all the time you can't take care of your
parents you can't take care of yourself
you can't take care of your rent you
can't live in a nice place you can't
take care of your car get your money
right okay what should you be spending
your money on why do wealthy people use
money not spend money why do wealthy
people buy businesses they don't buy
homes why do wealthy people use debt to
grow their business they don't use debt
to consume products and services why do
wealthy people not invest in 401ks and
seps and retirement accounts they don't
even worry about that they worry about
getting their money so freaking right
they can go wherever they want day or
night is saying hey man if you got a
million dollars you're basically just a
freaking deadbeat
and that your daddy didn't tell you that
if you didn't have any more income and
you were
how old are you 27. you're 27 years old
I'm gonna do this at 47 I'm gonna do it
at uh at 65. 27 you don't have any more
income how long would that money last
at four thousand dollars a month
you got 25 years where can you live on
four thousand dollars a month you'd have
to live on four thousand dollars a month
for 25 years you will be 52 years old my
friend
and dead Brook
number one thing you got to do is this
you got to change the Target and you
need to look at the Target daily the
target you have the wrong Target right
now if you're struggling you have the
wrong target
when you change the target Everything
Changes yeah and and I started with zero
just so you guys know I didn't have
anything okay so look it's simple Target
what's your new Target
yeah freedom but but but let's put my a
number on it
so your first Target should be 10
million dollars and nothing short of
that number one the target number two
you need to get your income to a place
this is a fascinating concept right here
okay if you can do this I guarantee
you'll be rich you need to get your
income not to what pays your bills but
to where you can save 40 of your gross
income is saved
all right so now now when you do this
math you're like dude how much money do
I actually need let's kick this up to 20
grand at 20 grand what happens
you're saving eight
storage you're paying eight
and now you can live on four see now
this is the right way to do a budget you
make thirty thousand
twelves going to storage
12 is going to the IR and the s
and that leaves you with six so now you
can start seeing that you got to be
somewhere north of 300 Grand a year this
is what they don't teach at Harvard
you got to be somewhere north of 360 a
year before you even have money to live
on unless you're just
you know your track
you're just an irresponsible human being
that that's
you know not putting storing money away
for the future
okay now you're saving 12 Grand a month
that's 144 000 in one year in 10 years
that's 1.4 million dollars in 10 years
you're a millionaire stored you guys
need to be heavily Money Motivated from
a survival standpoint okay number three
thing you're gonna do
you're going to go broke right here and
invest
the storage
has to get invested
the Golden Goose is only good If She
lays eggs
otherwise you can kill her eat her for a
chicken
need eggs bait money needs to make
babies
right so your goal right here is to
invest
to invest the storage money
and continue to do that until this money
over here the passive money
is equal
to
your income
right so what would I do I'd go out I'm
gonna make 30 grand I'm gonna store 12
I'm gonna pay the IRS I'm gonna live on
six Warren Buffett says don't lose money
number one number two don't lose money
I would tell you number three don't lose
money and that's the reality of the
situation that's what Peter Thiel was
saying a single digit millionaire cannot
even provide themselves with their own
personal defense in America
okay Hulk Hogan all that money Hulk
Hogan made he blew it all
he blew it off probably buying hair
pieces okay he blew it all he blew it
all ended up with a little money thought
he was oh man I got a little money until
he had that freaking lawsuit and then he
can't even defend himself
so it happens to a lot of people how
many how many of you know a family
member lost her job okay how many of you
have a family member where the kid got a
drug addiction he had to go to to rehab
for 30 days and it cost 40 Grand bad
happens how many of you know
somebody got cancer
okay how many know somebody in your car
accident costs three or four hundred
grand
happens
okay the problem is not that
happens it happens and people aren't
ready for it oh God I can't believe this
happened to me oh really
God damn you've been around long enough
right how many of you can't swim
[Laughter]
if you live on a planet with water I'm
just saying you might want to get a
swimming lesson
it's a wet Planet I love baseball but
but but you don't have to love baseball
to be to be inspired by greatness watch
this watch this watch yes
so beautiful look at this
isn't that amazing wow greatness man
that's greatness I got that guy he you
know when you when I watch that I'm like
I wonder how many times he's run jumped
Taking Flight pitch I mean thousands and
thousands and thousands of times to get
to have that moment right there so by
the way that's that's in everybody here
okay so if you ever see a great ball
play uh whether it's football or hockey
or ballet or dancing and you're inspired
it's because it's it's hitting that part
of you that's like you have that in you
you got every everywhere you go you need
to you need to confront every time you
hit up against oh the room's 249. the
the mill is 25 bucks uh Starbucks is six
dollars the airline flight costs 600
every time you like oh
okay you need to understand that you're
being reminded you don't have enough
money it has nothing to do with the
price
but but watch how much people
disassociate
oh American Airlines is charging too
much in that ticket
that has nothing to do with it you don't
you don't make enough money
okay so I had a guy I was in Oakland
California I was flying back and I said
uh hey anybody want to fly home with me
the guy's like oh I want home with you
I'll do it I said good I'll be 48 000
for fuel oh oh I don't want to do it
no you can't do it because you don't
have the money fuel is not the problem
he didn't he doesn't make enough money
so just start flipping things so like
now when I see wagyu remember that wagyu
we ate in Vegas it was like 115 for a
strip that big never do it again by the
way but the fact that I complained about
it only means
I don't make enough money
and if the wager is too much money
it's the 115 for a little strip of
wagons too much money
what does that say about what I'm
selling my products for
charging them up can't get enough I have
this idea so it's really to me it's
really
we go to Paris men and we go to the
Chanel store and there's people in line
in line out the front door at the Chanel
store I'm like oh my God great
experience for me
how much money is on this planet go to
Monaco see the Yachts 200 million 240
300 million dollars 300 million they
cost 30 million a year to take care of
them great experience
flying private been a great experience
for me I was 50 50
s old and I had a problem I was
depressed
I wasn't satisfied I was hungry but
didn't know what to do I had businesses
I had money I had a whole bunch of stuff
but I'm like dude what am I doing now
I'm bickering with Elena
we had our kids
we had the first two kids and we're like
okay we got a kids I'm being a parent
now okay I'm being a married guy right
I'm being a businessman and I'm unhappy
and then I started asking people what's
wrong man what's wrong what's wrong with
me man something wrong with me something
wrong with me oh yeah and as soon as you
say something wrong with me and
everybody's got an opinion
oh yeah man man you got a disease man
you got a problem you got issues man you
work too much you're a work addict
you you you you you you're insecure your
daddy died your daddy dad and left a
hole in you
left a hole in me I can't go on a
vacation
I want to do something man
doing less has never solved my problems
doing less moderation has never solved a
problem for me the problem that I've had
in my life okay was not my marriage
there's not okay I'm not a bad parent
I wasn't helping enough people
you should be up here you should be
dropping out of the ceiling you should
be helping more people if you guys look
around man it would appear to me that 99
of the people that you run into today
are having some kind of financial
problem
oh 76 percent of Americans live paycheck
to paycheck I know people that don't
live paycheck to paycheck that worry
about money every second of every day
when my dad died
I didn't know anything about the one
percent but I knew I wanted to get in
that club I'm like I have to get above
whatever this middle class thing is
because there's no safety here it's
constant fear I've only wanted money for
one reason to be out of fear so I could
help out so I could give to Charities I
could help my brother so I didn't have
to worry about how much the fuel costs
or do I run an ad budget or not man you
guys got to get out of the fear man
that's the whole purpose okay the fear
by the way is not a conspiracy that
is real everybody like oh fear ain't
real yeah well uh it's easy for you to
say you ain't got any this second
okay because it ain't scary to write a
damn quote or to post something on
Instagram that ain't scary what's
scary is going to take a loan for 60
million dollars
see if you ain't got a little bit of
scare
okay say no to a customer hey man you're
wrong okay my daughter told me the other
day customer driver is Right papa no
they're not no they're not and most
people don't even know how to tell a
customer they're wrong I lost my dad
when I was 10 I lost my brother when I
was 20. I lost you know I I gave up my
career and maybe I'm gonna be a baseball
player to drugs I've lost five or six
jobs now and I'm a loser I'm a total
loser but I do have this little This
Little Light inside of me that says I'm
special I have this little thing inside
of me and says hey you you are special
you know you have something but it was
just covered up in all this stuff and
all these problems and the in the drugs
and the bad friends and the bad choices
so my Mom finally says enough is enough
don't come back here anymore I'm done I
could tell it was hard for her
I'm in a treatment center in the next 24
hours
I go to this treatment center I'm there
30 days for the first 30 days and seven
eight nine years I don't use drugs
oh wow I don't have to use drugs finally
that thing where I said I was quitting
10 times a day I was quitting 10 times a
day for the first time in my life I was
able to quit successfully
I'm leaving the treatment center when
the insurance ran out because that's how
those work
when the money runs out they boots you
to the curb I'm terrified scared to go
back to society I don't have any friends
that aren't using drugs my girlfriend
was using drugs everybody around me
everybody I knew used drugs and I'm
going back to a job where even at the
job I had they used drugs and I'm like
I'm going back to an environment I have
to cut off all my friends
not really friends I got to cut off all
the enemies right and I got to start
over and before I leave the counselor
grabs me and the counselor says to me
look dude I'll see you back here
probably you know if you don't die I'll
see you back here and I'm like what are
you talking about dude I'm not coming
back here and he's like Oh no you're
coming back
and then he gives me the lecture
he's like you'll never make it
see when you go to a treatment center
you tell them everything about your life
like all your secrets all your your your
your your your your your
inhibitions and and your
the things you want to do in your life
right and so
I'm telling them in this thing
everything I've done everything I've
done wrong I share my whole life but I
also share with them what I want to do
my inspiration in life I'm going to
write books I'm going to speak to
audiences I'm going to help people I'm
going to tell people the story about
drugs and how damaging they are and I'm
going to be somebody I tell them and
they're like no no no no no but you're a
drug addict
and all you're ever going to be is what
the counselor tells you all you're ever
going to be is a drug addict you need to
give up all the ideas of writing books
speaking to audiences
being rich I always wanted to be rich I
wanted financially to be rich my whole
life I wanted to be my dad I wanted to
be the guy that could take care of his
family they said you need to give up all
those ideas and settle for one thing not
using drugs I just got uh awarded
awarded this deal 92.5 million dollars
31 acres in land my buddy Evan
Carmichael talks about dream believe
yeah but dream what and believe what
believe you pay your bills or believe
you can one day write a check for 60
million bucks what do you believe what
are you going to dream of
like literally I think people's dreams
are one of the things holding them back
because they don't know how to dream I
don't know how big to drink this is
doable for any person I don't care who
you are anybody could do this deal
anybody could do that deal I know the
guys that own private jets they're no
smarter than anybody else
they're not smarter they don't work
probably don't even work any harder
[Music]
but they did they did think bigger and
you can't you can't catch whales in a in
a bowl goldfish Bowl Money Follows
attention Money Follows attention all
right
hey hey
how much attention can you guys get
okay most of you can't get attention
because your mom and daddy said
don't get too much attention
don't get too much attention be seen
and not heard
fly under the radar
because if you get too much attention
they're going to shoot you down
right how many heard this before fly
under the radar man stay low man don't
let anybody see me you making moves
don't make moves man don't make moves
and then everybody wonders why can't I
get above
because you don't get attention
strangers have everything you want
everything you want a stranger has it it
will be strangers that will grow your
business
it will be strangers that put your kids
through schools it will be strangers
that make your dreams a reality
strangers have everything you want but
you were taught not to talk to them we
can't
we don't tell our kids that how many of
you are told this kids be careful
that's why you guys think so much you
got you got Dave Ramsey on TV saying
total freedom
comes from
not having debt
okay you got you you flip channels and
you go to Susie you can't afford that
okay I'm gonna tell you do you can
afford anything
no no no
hey that's not your problem okay I got
four four I probably got 500 million
dollars worth of debt today
500 million I wish it was 5 billion I
had to get over drugs
went to treatment center spent 28 days
in a treatment center when I was 25 my
mom my brother and my sister all gave up
on me
like they're like enough that's how bad
of trouble I was in I was using I was
using drugs every 45 minutes
I wasn't using drug once or twice a day
I was using once or twice an hour
whatever you're not going to do with the
business being you probably shouldn't be
doing a period
so I had to clean up I had to clean up
my deal man
28 days I got 28 days first 28 days of
my life in seven years that I didn't use
drugs I was like man what am I
going to do now my fear wasn't using
drugs again my fear was what am I going
to do with all my time
so when you see me run right now I'm
running from one thing to the next thing
trying to stay busy
because as long as I stay busy I don't
get in trouble by the way I'm the guy
that couldn't pay his rent
275 dollars a month in rent and I
think 25 I recommitted to my education
but this time I started studying nothing
were in books but people that it acts
created wealth
not people that it made money but people
that did creative wealth this is
completely different I was no longer
studying accounting and economics I was
studying wealthy people and only wealthy
people I'm not talking about the doctor
that was a neighbor that makes a million
dollars a year and he's working 18 hours
a day and he hates his job
right he's working seven days a week he
can't ever spend time with pain I'm
talking about the yacht people I'm
talking about the people that are
spending as much time as they want on
vacation I'm talking about the car
dealer that had uh 28 car dealerships or
82 car dealerships that has indisposable
money I'm talking about DeWalt and money
you're talking about The Waltons last
week increase their net worth by 11
billion dollars and they haven't worked
for 30 years
that's the kind of wealth I started
studying I started reading Barons in the
Wall Street Journal and I quickly
realized something that the wealthy
people
had Financial Freedom and no one else
did okay a very small percentage of
people lots of people have money my
uncle had millions of dollars he was
terrified about his money wouldn't spend
it acted like a miser buried money in
the backyard
I realized my parents had it wrong the
information I had that was wrong and
this is the number one thing I want you
to get out tonight
the information you have is wrong
the wealthy talked differently than the
middle class I watched my mom and my dad
I started comparing the wealthy people
to what my dad did my dad worked every
day every day of the week if he wasn't
working at the office he was working in
the yard
they saved money they cut their own
grass okay we ate all our food we turned
the lights off we didn't waste anything
and that was uncertainty it was
insecurity and it was fear and it
perpetuated uncertainty insecurity and
fear and and all the lessons about money
money doesn't grow on trees a penny
saved is a penny earned eat all your
food people are starving okay money
money you don't waste it don't play with
it all that creates insecurity and it's
incorrect if you want things to change
they can change
and they're not going to change just
because you pray
just because you wish just because you
hope and they won't change just because
your family wants it to change it it did
not change until I started getting
information
and if you're taking notes today it
didn't start changing until I started
getting rid of information one of the
most important things that happened to
me in my life was to get rid
of information
a man told me once he's like hey look
man if things aren't going well somebody
or something is causing it not to go
well how many agree with that statement
okay things aren't going well something
or someone is causing
things not to go well different game
today folks different game man
everything's changing remember when you
waited for a taxi cab
remember that when was that how many
people on this planet complained about
having to wait on a dirty cab
millions and millions and millions of
people said oh my gosh hey man let's
just send it to them if you can close
the distance between an idea and money
okay
you'll get rich when I was a kid when I
was growing up
the guy that the guy that knew how to
take care of his environment was my dad
I was eight years old and then this dude
this dude controlled everything in this
environment
after early for work he came home late
took care of his family and you knew he
never gave anybody a lecture about what
to do
he he just lit he was a good example
and um
and he had the money and he made the
money
we were middle middle class family so we
were like
Little Red Brick House White brick
actually white Brick House about 1400
square feet seven people lived in it
and my dad I could tell my dad was
trying to get somewhere he was trying to
move us up
he was trying and he wasn't trying to
brag
he was trying to take care of
and so I was watching that right and I
watched where this guy he he's the one
that made the decision where we went how
long we stayed and I started associating
that the money maker makes the rules
this is what Elena was talking about you
know there's around the money I make the
rules around the money around other
things Elena makes the rules so you got
to know what you're good at what your
job is and what your role is my dad and
my mom knew their roles
[Music]
the problem with that is when my dad
died suddenly at 52 years old my mom was
left
to do something she didn't she didn't
have she was not skilled up to do
and and I was 10 and I wasn't I didn't
know how to help my mom
and my dad left a little bit of
insurance money from the from the life
insurance or the death Insurance better
better it's really Called Death
Insurance just can't sell it if they
call it that and
my mom didn't know how long that money
would last so immediately after my dad
died when my mom should have been in
grief she went immediately into massive
fear and I could see it I could sense it
as a 10 year old my mom was in fear
every day
clipping coupons saving money
you know turn the lights off
eat all your food it was constant
messages
go across town to get gas like
everything you can't buy strawberries
today
you know they'll be they'll be 20 cents
cheaper tomorrow everything was about
fear
and so I I couldn't do anything about it
or didn't think I could do anything
about it
and I just kept telling myself one day
one day I'm gonna be in a position to
change this
and I think that really drives me today
to like
take care of
people not be in that situation again my
buddy dummy right here
never moves
you can come hit on him as much as you
want slapping reminds me of first
like
25 years of my life
see right here
I just take it never moved but I look
good
wouldn't read
just a damn dummy there's this old thing
about people read 60 books I could take
one book and read it 60 times if it's a
good book I don't abandon that book for
a second book I'm like I'm gonna dig in
now the the free the shipping on the
books I get an idea for a real estate
book
I should do a real estate book
everybody's asking me every day do a
real estate book do a real estate book
oh I'm gonna write a book we write a
book on real estate do I sell the book
or do I give the book away for free
why don't we do both
let's see who wants to give me 25 bucks
in shipping and let's see who wants to
get it for free and shipping
we did almost 80 000 books in six weeks
that's the most books I've ever done
right the whole process took 30 days
idea monetize we made money on the book
before I had the book in print I got an
idea right here everybody in the room's
got ideas everybody agree
the problem is they don't they don't get
the money fast enough the shorter the
runway between the idea and money the
more successful the business is going to
be my first book had over 600
grammatical errors run on sentences
prepositions in the wrong place
exclamation marks colons where there
should have been semicolons I had people
like dude you got you this book's got
misspellings on every page I'm like it's
a best-selling book
you know the guy that told me that never
read you never never wrote a book
he's so busy reading books and not doing
anything
by the way how many books have you not
written you don't have more money folks
because now it's not it's not because
you don't work it's not because you're
not a good person it's not because you
overspend it's not because you got too
much debt it's not because you don't
bust your ass
it's because your money doesn't bust its
ass your money is lazy if your money was
employees you would fire your money
here's the rules okay number one the the
money the extra money should go into
something that gives you money you want
your money to have babies the Golden
Goose is no long no longer good if she
doesn't have
eggs
the only thing that makes the Golden
Goose valuable is the fact that the
Golden Goose lays legs lays eggs so if
you just study the wealthiest families
in the world not just in America in the
world over long periods of time look at
the Queen the Queen of England
this much property and one of the
richest families in the world why they
get cash flow every month
from India from England from Ireland
from all over the world why why are the
princes in Saudi Arabia so wealthy
because they have constant inflow
of money coming from the land that
produces the oil the oil comes out of
the land and produces cash flow the
railroads the railroads back in the day
what'd they do they got all this land
together and then they rented that land
out to everybody around it why do all
the teachers Credit Unions take all the
money from all the teachers around
America and then they start investing in
real estate that produces cash flow so
they can distribute back to their
members
I'm always going to come back to this
one story look real assets that produce
real cash flow every month
when it pays you every month and you're
getting reminded every month I got a
check I got a little hundred dollar
check I got a 200 check this month I got
a 13 000 check today from one of my
properties every month I get a check for
13 Grand for my property it's a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars a year it
didn't start like that it used to be
like 1300 bucks thirteen hundred then it
was 26 then it was five thousand next
thing you know is 13 Grand that's one
property pays me every month
property just sits there okay it just
sits there it might not even change in
value it just sits there and produces
cash flow anything that produces cash
flow will be worth more money tomorrow
that's why Netflix is valuable why
because people pay a lot of cash into
Netflix and even if Netflix loses money
today some company will find Netflix
desirable for one reason
cash flow is King before you start
getting all oh God damn dude look this
is stupid
these cars
that you're seeing people by
I think 50 Cent got six of them for
Christmas or something I got my wife a
cullinan and I got myself this this is
ridiculous you don't need to go out and
buy these cars okay this is
without a doubt complete waste of money
and unlike unlike some of the people
that are out buying because there's a
lot of young kids right now thinking oh
I'm gonna go buy a Lambo I'm gonna get a
Ferrari I'm gonna go buy me a rose I
watched a 24 year old kid by a
Rolls-Royce I'm like man that don't even
look good on you even if you can't
afford it what you see right here is
completely ridiculous but years 35 years
of hard work not just hard work but
making good decisions and putting the
money away putting the money away and
not doing this kind of stuff
put all this stuff off don't do this
right now okay pay the price right now
work hard get great at your job get
great at whatever you do so good that
people are like man you're the best well
who are you what do you want they start
asking questions about wow what makes
you so unique
then you're going to start getting paid
more there's no way on this planet that
if if people know if people start
talking about how exceptional you are
you will get paid more at some point
when you do take that money and invest
it in something where you can't lose it
where it pays you every month and one
day in the future it'll be worth more
than it is today do that for years it
might take 10 years 15 years 20 years
I'm just starting to enjoy my life
a lot of hard work man you can't stay
connected to the why I don't mean why am
I doing this but you got to dig down the
why behind the why behind the Y right
why do I want to lose weight why do I
want to be in better shape why
because it because it because it's gonna
make me healthy but why do you want to
be healthy why did I start investing in
real estate
and by the way why did I start making
more money so I could have more money to
invest in real estate why do you want to
make more money so you can have more
money to invest in real estate why oh
because I want to spend more time with
my kids man because I want to be on a
vacation with my kids and not worry
about what we're doing I want to be able
to go to sleep or go travel or do
whatever I want and I got money coming
in and I want to be able to take care of
my parents and my church and my charity
I want to take care of stuff after I die
that's why I invest in real estate no
more drinking no more drugging no more
weekends until I get my money right just
like job sales second thing I would do
is this I would invest
my extra time
not my money my extra time I would
invest learning about real estate
without a doubt if I would have been
doing this at 20 years old I'd be worth
over a billion dollars today
all I had to do was Focus different what
I did was I got caught up in this first
job
and I started thinking about how good I
was doing
one day looked up I was 35 years old 33
years old actually and my uncle says you
need to start paying attention
to your money
to money working he said it to me one
time man one piece of advice I got from
my uncle
he's like you need to start paying
attention you need to get your money
working I'm like okay thanks you need to
hate your life you guys don't need to
like I'm good I'm all happy I'm good I'm
I'm living the dream you need to get so
disgusted I told you this eight years
ago get so disgusted with your life
get so freaking like you hate your life
so much that that the thing that the
where you go every day is a solution to
getting the life you want people keep
asking me dude how do you keep your
freaking Mojo going like
it it's like it's like you got more
energy I said well it's a beautiful
having a beautiful wife thank you
handsome women women let's just call us
beta space women are the super uh
motivators of the universe this is my
muse right here oh God in addition to
the Muse though okay okay it's a new me
this year folks really in addition to
the Muse you guys got to have a pull
you need to have a pool you're like man
how do you stay how do you stay so
motivated it's the pull it's not the
push Jordan wins a ring and he's like
okay now what everybody else is out you
know drinking champagne but this the
true Champions are like what's the next
thing what's the next move what do we do
next like you need the next thing to
keep them going but when am I ever gonna
be satisfied you need a pool you're
never going to be satisfied and if you
are by the way by the way if you are
satisfied you quit the speed
at which
you commit
determines your velocity
how fast I can commit to something will
determine how fast I can move into that
thing and how much power I have okay the
speed at which you commit the longer you
take to commit to something
the less impact it's going to have on
your community on yourself on your life
on your money your finances I don't care
if it's rehabbing your kitchen
buying a house
and making an investment in real estate
the speed at which you can commit dude I
want to collaborate with people I don't
want to compete anymore I'm done with
competition so when you hear when
you hear a such thing I think of me you
everything you hear all that early sales
stuff from me I was in such a
competition mode
it was I was competing with everybody I
thought it was me against everybody
and really it's just been in the last
since we did that first growth
conference and we had other people on
stage and I didn't do like I didn't do
any of the speaking Yeah I was just
introducing people doing interviews and
walking uh doing doing Q and A's
even the second even the second one even
Russell Brunson says dude why would you
why are you giving up all your stage
time to other people because I want to
collaborate yeah and and but then we
figured that the other people don't
really know how to do it yet like
they're like hey follow my Instagram I'm
like that's not a collaboration we don't
care about your Instagram when I took I
spent six million dollars trying to get
30 000 people in a room yeah right now
we care about where is everybody going
for the next through next year and 2020.
your surroundings have to change
okay the people your network your
scenery you will not change your life
until you change the people in your life
my daddy abandoned me
my sister's not gonna like hearing that
because she's gonna be like oh my God he
was good to you he died
he left me too soon
period
call it whatever you want okay he left
me too soon
he left my brother too soon okay me and
my brother went without a dad man
tremendous amount of energy
same kind of like like just imagine me
as a 10 year old in Louisiana
with a weapon
right
I'm 10 years old we we had a 22 right
foot I'm out shooting everything that
moves
cars
anything anything and everything I'm
wild man I'm wild I got all this energy
and I don't have a dad and I'm angry I
told my mom when I was 16 years old one
day one day I'm going to be successful
one day one day I'm gonna be successful
and one day I'm gonna help a lot of
people
and I said that to her because I wanted
somebody to help me
see I've always loved helping people
always I am most happy when I'm helping
someone else
nothing to do with money
if I can help somebody
not give them something but if I can
actually help somebody to feel better
about themselves
to know what to do in a phone call to
know what to do on a sales call to know
how to follow up their girlfriend or
their boyfriend or to solve some problem
in their life or how to get some money
if I can help somebody know how to do
that I know I contributed to their life
Sabrina can't set the right goals right
now everybody agree with that Sabrina
can't she can't pick up 200 pounds
you understand she can fly on a jet one
of my kids has never been on a
commercial airline she's like Papa will
I ever get to fly a commercial
I hope not
I hope you never have to go through that
it's wrong
I did three million miles so you don't
have to peanuts I didn't want and I was
doing that on Thanksgiving holidays to
go to Canada where they were they were
still transacting does this Super Bowls
I've missed ball games I've missed my
buddies were traveling seeing the world
and I didn't have any of those
experiences it's been 30 years 30 years
it's probably going to be 30 years for
you too it's going to be 30 years of it
are you willing to pay the price if
anybody thinks you're going to be
successful without paying that price
[Music]
you're wrong earn money learn how to
store the money and learn how to use it
because if you can't do this if you
can't flow the money back out if you're
sitting on a grand right now or two
grand or five grand make it official
that you're broke
do not try to save five grand
it's no money
just make it official get rid of it
and be broke
because you're broke already and maybe
you'll hustle now like you need to
replace your reserves that's why when I
earn some money I store it okay if if I
store 30 million dollars I know I'm
getting rid of it twice a year I dump
everything I have entire every penny I
have does not go into some emergency
account it goes into an asset that will
make babies
or make me known
and you guys can do this
everybody in the room can do this okay
if I can do this you guys can do this
you need a network a team of people
around you that can hold you accountable
you will go nowhere by yourself not even
Jesus went by himself
nobody goes by themselves nobody
all right you have more potential you
know it if that's the answer to that get
there be VIP while you're there too by
the way VIP
have a VIP experience
if you can VIP yourself why do you think
somebody else is going to treat you like
a VIP I don't know where I am most the
time I don't know what day it is I don't
know what time it is I just know hey I
got this moment man right here let's
make the most of this moment
I don't know if I live once or twice
okay I know this I need to take
advantage of what I have right now and I
can't do that by myself I don't want to
be by myself we don't want to just be
the four of us I don't want to just be
me Elena Sabrina and Scarlet I wanna I
wanna I want a nation I don't want a
tribe I don't want to drive I want
friends all over the world I want
Sabrina and Scarlet when they grow up
and they go to to Switzerland they have
friends in Switzerland okay if the World
falls apart we have friends in Oklahoma
or in central or maybe I got to go to
South America for a while maybe I gotta
go hang out okay I will not fulfill my
mission my mission is to help people
I will be known for the people I help
not the money I made nobody's going to
remember nobody's going to say 50 years
from now 100 years from now oh Grant
Cardone had a great chat nobody nobody
will ever mention that
my books might live on okay my audio
will guarantee you my audio will live
long after I'm dead
but your memories with me you using our
Technologies okay we'll live on forever
you live on through other people Walt
Disney did it he lives on today man okay
build a legacy folks build a legacy put
yourself out there okay 10x your lives
10x in the lives of the people around
you getting ready to do a real estate
conference for a thousand experienced
and mature Real Estate Investors if you
knew what I was going to share with them
the one biggest most important number in
all the real estate investing there's
one thing if you read my book you know
what it is I'm gonna share it with them
today and it's going to blow the top off
their heads there's some people in the
room that are retired from apartment
investing and they're gonna I guarantee
you when I'm done today they're going to
be like
honey what was we thinking getting out
of this game we got to get back in it we
did it wrong because we did it small
hey if you're not invested in apartments
seriously if you're not investing in
apartments if you don't know the game
how to learn the game learn the game
figure the game out I promise you with
every fiber of my being I believe that
apartment investing will prove to be
over the next 25 years the single best
investment up here
that you could possibly make your life
is not the way it should be then you
should hate yourself right now I don't
blame you you should the best way but
dude I I hated my before I love my
I hated myself so bad I couldn't look in
the mirror
Jared told me the other day he's like
you don't have a mirror in your bathroom
let me bring you in there right now sure
there's no mirror on there check this
out
I said dude I don't need a mirror I
remember you know what that bathroom I
remember having an apartment where I
couldn't put a mirror on the wall broke
it
broke it I broke the mirror look at that
right there there ain't no mirror that I
told Sarah yesterday I said dude I don't
have a mirror I I said I don't care I
don't need to look at myself I remember
when I look at myself and I hated myself
broke the mirror out of my bathroom
because I couldn't look at my face
all right
because the mirror remind me every time
I had a mirror I was putting something
on it to put it in my face
hated myself man hated myself didn't
have any money
had all this potential
overdosing daily that's one man you want
to change you got a bunch of potential
tell you tell yourself the truth
okay do you have more potential than
you're using
ask yourself right now just ask yourself
just meditate on this a second
do I have more potential than I'm using
do you guys should ask yourself that
every morning when you wake up man
what are you say to yourself in the
morning first thing I do in the morning
I wake up and say do I have more
potential thank you Alex do I have more
potential than I'm using dude if I do
if it's even this much then I gotta get
the up and go get it
this is where God lives dude this is the
spiritual part of life it's the seeking
of potential not the seeking of
Serenity and happiness Serenity and
happiness are selfish
Commodities it's about me man for me to
seek my potential the next level means I
gotta give up what I have
that's where God lives man
God's proud of Grant Cardone you know
what a bunch of humans don't like Grant
God loves Grant
yo you know what because God's like dude
that guy he will put it out there you
guys all praying you know what my
prayers my prayers not talking to God my
prayer is taking action I've been busted
broke and beat up
I've been I've been at a point in my
life where I thought I thought less than
me than anyone thought of me how many
have been there
dude how do I get the right girl the
right family the right money the right
company the right employees I don't even
like me
foreign
what happened I had more money when I
was eight than when I was 25.
what happened
I liked myself more when I was six years
old then I was 25 years old what
happened to me now if you look at me
today six years old and 57 dude I'm kind
of digging myself right now
I like who I am man I've spent the last
years just doing one thing dude working
on who I am number one most important
thing Warren Buffett says and I study a
lot of people okay this year I'll
probably spend this year between mentors
which really my mentor is just the guys
to hook up he's hooking me up with other
players between mentors I don't think I
say the word right
books courses I'll go out for three
weeks and just do a course you guys
worry about a weekend
I can't get away for a weekend did I go
for three weeks and just do courses
I'll probably spend 400 Grand this year
man
see you and I were brought up to worry
about what
this what's in your pocket
[Music]
I I mean I used to squeeze the quarter
so hard at fly
and scream
[Music]
look look look everybody worries about
this right
[Music]
but whose money is this
somebody else's money man this ain't my
money I've already got to work out in
spent time with my kids did a project in
my office because we were doing some
construction there on my way to an event
and then we'll leave there go to another
event in another city
about uh 2 000 miles away all in the
in the that's what I say my brothers my
sisters my nephews and my nieces all
business all weekend yeah I don't think
people get out enough
the best things that have happened to me
in my life was when I left my room
my house
even the city that I lived in
and um
I think we stay home too much guys get
out
ladies leave your house get out
okay go out into the world
see what's there even get her get up
early to do it
again the best things that have happened
to me in my life happened outside my
house 29 years old left the house
moved to Houston I was terrified
I know somebody think oh man where are
they scared of nothing I was so scared
to move
out of Lake Charles it was like one of
the most terrifying things I've ever
done in my life once I got there I was
like that I don't even know what I was
scared about I lived there for uh I
don't know two uh three four or five
five years maybe
then I moved to La Jolla California
didn't know one person there
had the life man I had the life in La
Jolla I mean it was unbelievable
I actually went there with a person a
girlfriend me and a girlfriend moved
there I
I got I moved there
she left about a year later maybe two
years later
I had the the single man's life
if you know what I mean
in La Jolla I had it made I was I was
loving life then I reached a point to
where I'm like uh I need to grow up now
I need I want a wife and I want kids I'm
on Grant Street look at that
I want to Wife and Kids
I knew that that person was not in Ohio
I'm talking to you about moving I'm
talking to you about getting outside and
talking to you about
leave man why have you been in one spot
so long
or maybe one spot you've been in for 10
years now you've moved once okay I left
I left La Jolla moved to Los Angeles
California just so you guys know nobody
goes from work how you doing sir nobody
nobody moves from La Jolla and goes to
L.A people voting from LA to Hawaii
have a great day huh
and uh
say again
oh thanks a lot appreciate it
hey guys on my book now you see how
would I need that customers
it's crazy dude
gotta get out gotta get out went to LA
lived in La for I don't know 12 years
had a maid in L.A had this unbelievable
house Lionel Richie's I'm bragging
get me wrong I lived in Lionel Richie's
house
flying out wasn't there anymore so it's
my house now I lived there and and uh
all the parties were at my house it was
three quarters of an acre flat lot in
the Hills above the Sunset Strip Doheny
drive and Oriole freaking I mean
spectacular place
we had our first two well we had our two
kids there in the house
all our friends had been there we got
married in that house I mean we were so
connected to that house it was
unbelievable Elena and I when we first
saw the house it was four times my
budget and I'm like we're behind that
house and you guys know how much I
believe
how much I am against buying houses we
fell so in love in that house in love
with each other in love with the house
in love with our kids there in love with
friends and parties and memories and and
decorations and antique furniture we
love that house and then it reached a
time where I'm like I think we got to
leave
we love
we were so comfortable there
sure enough five years ago I got up and
moved to Miami we've been in Miami five
years now we've traveled all over the
world we're constantly moving my daddy
told me Dr care our local doctor he was
the most successful doctor in the in in
we knew both the most successful doctors
Dr Karen Dr Morin right and Dr care was
at the house and they're drinking
martinis I'm like damn I'm gonna do that
too I'm gonna drink martini and I'm
gonna be James Bond
right and Dr Cara came up to me and says
give me a dollar I had a Dollar too he's
like give me that dollar I'm like I'm
giving you a dollar my daddy said never
deny a man in power
never deny a man in power okay never
talk poorly about somebody in power
push power to power
that's a good investment folks okay if
you're taking notes write this down push
power to power people that are doing
good things people that are making a
difference people that are out there
push power to power and ignore everyone
else
we don't help people that have nothing
I'm telling you right now I do not help
people that have nothing
I had I help people that have something
and want to make it more I'm not talking
about money right now
if somebody thinks they have nothing I'm
not helping that person if they think
they have nothing I can't help them if
you think you have something
and that you're not broke
I can help you if I take these people
right here
what do these people spend money on and
what do these people spend money on
remember rich is waiting to be poor
Earth waiting to get wealthy but it
ain't wealthy yet
what do the poor people y'all want to do
poor Rich first
because let's do the poor people poor
people spend money on just give me give
me anything what's something
okay yeah yeah good a watch
I gotta have a techno Marine that's what
I used to call it
I gotta have me some fake Gucci
it's not even real Gucci
it's Gucci from the Kana okay oh oh my
big goal in life is to buy a house this
guy's stuck in this too I'm gonna buy a
house one day I'm gonna be a prisoner
the warden and the Prisoner
okay it's the castle
trips trips right trips pleasure
okay uh VIP VIP this is my boy Alan VIP
in bottles bottle service
right cars okay cars
uh belts
okay let me see my belt today
I got my belt dog
Where'd I spin on this belt
29 man 29 dollars
okay
watch
alert
my self-esteem is good today I left it
in the Box
now what do these people buy what do
these people invest money on network
networking
these people are heavy heavy on who they
know man
okay charity why charity because charity
is networking
who's at a charity event people that are
chairing a ball if you didn't spend any
time in charity events last last year I
guarantee you got a money problem
this is connections okay these are
networking and connections the first
thing the rich people spend their money
on is connections wealthy people spend
their time with wealthy people we've
heard that over and over and over again
okay Investments these people invest
money they don't spend money these are
Spenders over here right I'm gonna buy a
watch it's gonna be worth a lot of money
one day dude it ain't gonna be worth any
money to who
oh my God man I'm gonna buy a paddock
and I'm Gonna Keep it for like three
generations and one day win you're dead
man
okay uh they invest in businesses they
buy franchises
uh we have people that buy Grant Cardone
license
those are people that have a wealthy
mentality why they want to buy a Grant
Cardone license because they can use my
name my trademarks my products and go to
Thailand and make money on my name
without me going to Thailand uh uh
marketing these people these people
spend money on marketing
you know I'm convinced
that Donald Trump did not have a plane
before he was the president because he
needed to travel places I'm convinced
Donald Trump had a plane so he could
park it at LaGuardia and advertise that
he's a rich dude
people see his name he left it right
there at LaGuardia Airport he didn't put
it in a private airport he put it at
LaGuardia so that every passenger that
leaves New York out of LaGuardia would
see his big bird
what are you spending your money on in
2019. human beings are trapped in as
Spiritual Beings they're trapped this is
what I believe I believe I believe the
spiritual being is trapped in a body
okay I believe I'm a spiritual being not
a human being the spiritual being would
have tremendous potential unbelievable
potential it would be the light on the
candle not the candle the body would be
the candle
okay and the spiritual being would be
the flame I I'm not I'm the flame and
and I want to see how hot can I burn
okay how far can I go how much light can
I bring the world how much positive
truth message can I bring this planet
how much more can I do and I think the
problem is people are settling out with
just enough pay the bills take care of
my family get my little box
look at my little house put my little
welcome mat on the front put the little
gate around the yard
we're all going to be happy I don't want
the Box
I don't want one location I don't need
to welcome that I want to know the world
I want to travel the world I want to do
more I want to be in more places I want
to have friends in every country I want
to inspire people in every language and
I want other people to see and they can
do the same thing you know and and maybe
maybe maybe at the end of all this I
just become everybody's uncle that I
never had if you're a business owner you
have to see the future if you're an
entrepreneur you have to look forward
into the future what's going to happen
next if you're driving a car it's
responsible to look ahead everybody
agree if you're skiing down a mountain
you might want to keep your attention
out in front of you if you're riding a
motorcycle you might want to not pay
attention to right where you are but
where you're going
pay attention to the Future what dreams
and goals do you have that are more
important than the money you have invest
money to hit your targets quit telling
yourselves lies about money exchange
money the only purpose of money is to
exchange money for time and connections
the only reason you have money is to
exchange money for time and people
you need people folks
you need people man you're you're going
to grow your business with people people
that work for you and people that you
sell products to be so obsessed
with the idea of freedom and making a
difference that you will do anything
anything I'll go into debt I'll spend my
last dollar this is how you're going to
be successful folks I'll borrow money
from my mom I borrow it from my dad I
borrowed from from family members I'll
go raise money I'll go back on the
street corner I'll go sell t-shirts and
hats failure after failure I'm obsessed
so much with my freedom that I'm willing
to talk to people even if I'm an
introvert
okay I'm willing to go talk to old
people if I'm young I'm willing to go
talk to young people if I'm old I'm
willing if I'm out of work I'm willing
to go take a dumb sales job just to get
my feet back underneath me
become so obsessed
that everybody's like
what's wrong with you man
you change it you got to change your
friends whoa if your friends
you need to make these people your
friends
people that have time to get away people
that are working
people that are creating
surround yourself with people that are
doing things
that that are seeking to be better I was
I was hanging around people that were
destroying themselves every day people
that were criticizing others that were
successful that were wasting time
beautiful Rock
they weren't looking for anything
except how everybody else was wrong
how they had been wrong I know because I
was doing this
spent all my time talking about
how the rich guy
that was had his kids in tennis classes
and golf classes and they had a boat and
they went skiing
how he was such a prick
and when reality sorry guys didn't mean
to hear that
when in reality she didn't hear that
when in reality I should have been
looking at here what did this guy do
to create a situation
where he could pay for his kids to learn
tennis if they want to golf
and skiing
I was asking the wrong questions
I would tell my 20 year old self change
the questions you're asking
change the way you look at things
quit being so resentful and hateful my
business is kind of different I own a
hair salon and I have started a brand
for myself and probably went about it
the wrong way I started it doing booth
rental instead of commission and in the
business I'm kind of maxed out at making
as much as I can make for the size so I
know I need to expand but I also know
that I have to be taken
serious as a woman and I feel like it's
a it's a difficult thing to do and I
don't want to do it the wrong way this
time so I don't really know how to be
taken seriously I'm petite I have blonde
hair I always have crazy fingernails or
sometimes it's purple sometimes it's
blue yeah
so I guess the question would be where
where do I go from where I'm at to get a
lot of attention I know I I think you
just got to get a lot of attention
you know everything the red the blue the
long nails the shortening anything that
gets attention like you have to get
people's attention you guys have to get
interesting
so again she doesn't like some of the
things I do I have to do that I believe
in my mind I have to do some of that to
capture attention whether that's true or
not true I don't know I don't know maybe
it's not true
you know I know this if somebody wants
to have a movie and it wants to be a
great movie at the theaters they got to
get a lot of attention to get somebody
to go to the movie you've got to be
willing to get people not to like you
and what does that look like just by
promoting so much that you irritate
people like what does it mean to get
people not to like Rush Limbaugh who's a
pretty pretty divisive guy
uh says uh
you know the people that love him listen
to him two hours a day and the people
that hate him listen to him for four
hours
people that hate him listen to him for
four hours a day
so I'm just saying everybody wants to be
liked yeah everybody wants to be the the
popular person you guys got to be
willing to tell people your hair looks
terrible oh I I mean I do I'm I'm
actually very very good at my job I just
don't know how to um take it take it to
the next level I guess maybe maybe I'm
scared or I have nothing what's your
website what's your Facebook
anyway right there nope the One
underneath that see I don't have a
picture of you so I'm going to go is
that is that you yes
or is that your kids
um that well there's a picture of me and
then it's my daughter yeah so I mean
I don't want to see your daughter right
now I want to see you right I have a
hair therapy page
um I don't it's under hair therapy yeah
I see hair therapy I see it right here
so so like right okay now we got the
dogs
she's a veterinarian right
so like okay now I got hair okay that's
good before and after round like like
you guys gotta like like get clear on
what the message is right she needs a
you need a personal you need a business
page
right the trick is you've got to get
attention Elena just wrote a book called
build an Empire okay she has to get
attention for the book which means leak
out data about the book not about
anything else but that book what is it
what chapter What audio what am I
listening to why am I listening to it
what do I get out of it like constant
pushing into whatever you do with hair
therapy okay
and and it's a good good but but dinner
date but what do I do with the dinner
date yeah
see like you
did this is where everybody's like
when's enough enough man when do you
just enjoy yourself
I don't know I'm gonna enjoy myself when
I'm in a position to just enjoy myself
you live on an economic Planet
regardless of your race regardless of
where you came from regardless of your
religion you live on a planet that has
two things on it gravity I can't fly
and I'm reminded every day of gravity
right or wrong every day day I'm
reminded I'm reminded of it so much I
don't even know that it's not just know
that I shouldn't be able to just seven
feet
[Music]
right
and number two
money every day you were reminded this
is a financial Planet okay I got a
little credit I don't have any cash on
me today none because I'm a real estate
guy
real estate guys are always broke
okay but I got me a little card
I can use this to open boxes
and I can use it to buy a box
right see how many were told all credit
credit cards are bad how many been told
debt is bad how many been trained that
oh oh all debt is bad debt I got about
500 million dollars worth of debt I got
to tell you I love it almost as much as
my wife and kids
I do love it man because it generates
income for me
now I'm telling you all this to tell you
look you have been miseducated if you're
having trouble with money it is because
you have the wrong data
it's not because you're stupid it's not
because you're lazy it's not because you
have a bad job okay I've had all those
excuses
you have the wrong information the first
25 years of my life I use the
information that is being disseminated
by TV and mass media
save your money say yeah if you heard
that one
okay you were brought up on that one if
you were brought up poor middle class
say yay
no no you can't say it like that say it
like you're proud yes I must blower
say yay
no no well you brought up poor middle
class
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you something it's going
to take you forever if you don't get
your freaking enthusiasm right look if
you're poor admit it
but damn I'm poor and then hate it
because you shouldn't be if you're in
the middle by the way if you're middle
class and you've got three meals a day
you got a car out there you can make the
payments on you got a little education
that you think is worth something and
it's not okay
and you got a good mom and a good dad
and you were brought up in a good family
good for you but dude that don't pay the
bills you ever ask yourself dude when
are you going to make it are you do you
ever suffer from this idea that you
could do more than you're doing
and no matter how much people around you
love you or
oh you're doing great patching the back
you're doing phenomenal amazing I've
been told my whole life I was doing
amazing I remember being I was 29 years
old I was the leading salesperson where
I where I worked
I mean I wasn't the best salesperson I
was the best sales person about like
three or four people
breaking records doing stuff that had
never been done
everybody's telling me how great I was
and I was like but I know I can do more
I don't know if that's suffering
suffering some kind of like mental
disease some kind of never satisfied
with I've heard all these people talk
about
I remember the guy said hey your
disappointments are
your disappointments in life are equal
to your expectations
suggesting that you not have
expectations
and if you lower your expectations then
you won't have disappointments I got to
tell you man I mean I can't even make
sense of that I'm like I have to have
expectations of myself I know I can do
better I know I can do more so
if me having big expectations of myself
I mean I'm going to be disappointed from
time to time that's the way it's got to
be the one other thing that I would tell
my 20 year old self look I own seven
businesses
and I would not tell you
I would not tell the 20 year old Grant
to go get six six businesses I would
tell him
to learn everything he can about real
estate
everything
real estate is the business that's
allowed me to go on these magnificent
trips that I'm taking my family on I've
been in business for myself for 30 years
okay six businesses do not
six businesses combined do not allow me
to go on these trips it is the real
estate by and of itself
that's allowed me to take my wife and
kids
employees Partners friends on these
magnificent trips when you're hanging on
somebody in your same space right or
they're hating on you remember this you
can focused on creating massive massive
success
okay because
when you get up to the top of the food
chain whatever the food chain is in your
space whether it's Financial or
insurance or real estate or influencers
or podcasters or maybe you're doing a
real business you're not doing it you're
not an influencer and you're not a
podcaster you're like who are all these
guys spending all this time doing
podcasts I got a business to grow I got
employees maybe you're doing that
so
what's my point
anytime you watch any of my videos you
say dude what's the guy really talking
about
I'm doing this for you I don't get paid
to do it
so if you're getting any value out of
this I'm telling you when you get up the
food chain and you will because you're
watching it you will get up the food
chain you will become a super successful
person but you won't if you hate
you will not become super successful
if you take the time
to worry about these other people in
your space flowing Power Man
love on them
send them love send them customers send
them deals but don't be surprised
when they don't send it back
because they're not
no book
tells you this
all these guys doing their little quotes
talking about abundancy scarcity but
watch how they act when you get up there
man watch it man it's gonna be crazy
you're gonna be like Cardone told me
while it didn't snow
the dude told me
that they were gonna hate on me I had I
had somebody call me the other day and
said hey dude I want to give you some
you need you need to know how to handle
some of these situations you're running
up against
okay because there's a way for you to
prevent some of this
some of this these people hating on you
I said dude I don't I'm not going to try
to prevent somebody from being stupid
that's just dumb I got enough Insurance
in my life already
most of the time the accident never
happens the way to ensure that these
haters and criticizers and little
thinkers don't bother you is don't be
them number one number two
flowing them loving power baby number
three number three number three get to
the top
get to the top of the food chain
where everybody at the top knows you
and the people that wouldn't flow you on
the way up
or wish they didn't do what they did we
saw the fight last night
just goes to show you man you can't take
eight months off eight months of
drinking and showing off and bragging
and running your mouth
you can still get cracked
you got you know huh
yeah too many days off man too many days
off got to pay the price every day folks
otherwise you lose
period you will get beat you're going to
get beat in the marketplace if you don't
train every day I'm wearing my card on
University t-shirt
because if you don't train every day
don't expect to make the sale
if you don't train every day when you
leave here do not expect your people to
follow up if you don't train every day
do not expect your people to answer the
telephone correctly if you don't train
every day do not expect your people to
be motivated to do the right thing if
you don't train every day if you don't
require training every day if it's not
mandatory every day you will not get the
cash flow
you will get just enough money
to pay the bills and by the way
everybody's got that figured out
everybody on the planet has figured out
how to pay their bills
even people that don't have any money
are figuring out how to eat everybody
agree so don't be bragging about your
bicycles and your two BMWs in your
country club that you paid for and the
roof over your head and you pay your
utilities and your gas and don't tell me
that all somebody else has got it worse
than you of course somebody else has got
it worse than you I hear this all the
time from people okay somebody gets
whacked they have a bad situation and
they're like but I'm grateful well you
mean you're grateful man you're filing
bankruptcy I know but I still got my
health
but you don't have your Financial Health
you shouldn't have gone bankrupt you
should have prepared for it don't make
sense of the failure okay if you're
taking notes quit making sense of the
failures I want to talk to you about the
cash flow
I'm talking about the cash flow not the
snow I'm talking about getting that
third flow you work your wife works yeah
y'all cracking some freaking smack daddy
money you getting some long green you
made your first million dollars last
year that's right between the two of you
after you paid your taxes you end up
with four or five maybe six hundred
if you know how to play the game but
what you don't have is number three
your cash don't work you got scared once
you put away your first Milli you and
the wife are like oh no what do we do
now you called your uncle not me not
Uncle G you called your other Uncle the
confused Uncle he said pay the house off
you called your financial advisor start
investing in 401ks in the IRAs
and then you saw something I said about
cash
is trash
a home is dumb Equity what are you doing
folks get that third flow it's like a
good snowstorm baby you need that third
flow when you can't work
you can't crank you can't create
the third flow of income is the one you
buy you take your dead money cash is
trash take that dead money get it
invested in hard assets
and only make a decision to invest in
those things that pay you cash flow you
invest cash you get back cash every
single month I want to tell you a story
when I grew up
my first failure
happened
in a baseball park
[Music]
I had a dream that I would be a
professional baseball player
and I lost that dream
to drugs
you guys don't give up on your dreams
I'm not here to Jack you up I'm not here
to get you excited I'm here to be an
example
I'm not your friend
I'm your uncle G two minutes with me
every day two minutes I go to the gym
and work out every day
's in a week all I ask you to do turn on
your computer
spend two minutes with me
every day
stop the boat
stop the Netflix
give me two minutes
give me two minutes you give me two
minutes every day
I'll change your life forever if you
want another amazing Grant Cardone video
check it out right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
I'll see you